major reforms are changing daily life
for millions of people in Saudi Arabia
an anti-corruption campaign led to the
house arrest of about 200 prominent
figures in the Ritz Hotel authorities
lifted a ban on female drivers earlier
this year and allowed women into sports
stadiums for the first time Holly
Williams is on the streets of Riyadh to
show us how and why things are changing
Holly good morning good morning what's
happening in Saudi Arabia is not a
revolution some crimes here is still
punished with beheading and women still
need permission from a male relative to
travel overseas but things are changing
just take a look at this this isn't
exactly what you expect to see in an
ultra conservative Islamic Kingdom but
comic-con has arrived in Saudi Arabia
just last year this celebration of comic
book superheroes with no gender
segregation would probably have been
shut down by the country's religious
police the crown Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman is the favorite son of Saudi
Arabia's ruler King Salman and he wants
to modernize the closed-off Kingdom we
saw him yesterday launching a new
anti-terrorism coalition the crown
prince is only 32 years old and he isn't
just the king's anointed successor
he's already enormous ly powerful in his
own right Prince Mohammed has used that
power to round up more than 200 members
of this Saudi elite all accused of
corruption locking them up in this
luxury hotel critics say the crown
prince is removing his rivals and
detractors but ordinary Saudis seemed
delighted it should have happened
earlier said Bandar ala Tybee who sells
hunting Falcons it's brought us great
happiness the Saudi Arabian royal family
has long depended on the support of
Islamic clerics
to rule this country of around 30
million the big question now is whether
these reforms will sooner or later spark
a backlash from conservative Saudis Nora
all right Holly Williams in Saudi Arabia
thank you so much